south africa's former president jacob
zuma is in police custody after turning
himself in
late on wednesday night a court
sentenced him to 15 months in jail
for failing to show up at a corruption
inquiry last week this is where zuma is
being held now
those graph charges stem from his time
in office police had been instructed to
arrest sumer
if he didn't turn himself in by the
deadline on wednesday he's challenged
his imprisonment
rulings expected on friday camila miller
has more from escort where he's being
detained
it was shortly before a midnight
deadline that the former president jacob
zuma's foundation
announced that he had decided to comply
with the incarceration order given by
the constitutional court a week ago
until now the former president had
resisted arrest he was supposed to have
given himself in
last sunday when that didn't happen
police
were instructed to arrest jacob zuma
but there were concerns around safety
and a potentially
volatile situation around in kandla in
kwazulu-natal where the former president
has a homestead and where he does enjoy
significant support
now to avoid any type of confrontation
between police
and supporters the former president then
took a convoy with his protection
service
to this correctional facility in escort
also in kwazulu-natal he's now handed
himself
in he's being processed and it's likely
this
is where he will spend at least the
first few days of his sentence
because once that processing is
completed
authorities determine the most suitable
correctional facility or accommodation
for
the former president given his age
and his health he'd previously said that
he shouldn't be imprisoned because he's
79 years old
he's unwell and south africa is
currently going through a third wave
of the covert 19 pandemic
you will know that as a former president
he has a presidential
protection unit he they brought
him to us but now we have to take over
to ensure that he is incarcerated in a
safe custody and also will have to
respond to his
special needs if any you know have been
identified
jacob zuma and his legal team have
submitted an application to be heard
by the constitutional court next week
and that's where he's hoping that either
the judgment
made that has found him guilty of
contempt of court will be rescinded
or at least his sentence reduced from 15
months
but before that he does have a pending
application at the high court
in peter maritzburg where he had asked
for the arrest
not to happen but that judgment is only
due on friday and that's why the former
president
has been incarcerated legal experts say
the likelihood
of that particular case being successful
is very slim and so the next time we
could possibly hear from the former
president
is next week when his lawyers represent
him at the constitutional court
possibly in mitigation of the sentence
even though it's after the fact
either way for many south africans it
may
be almost unbelievable that jacob zuma
the former president
who hasn't been held accountable until
now
who faces a number of corruption charges
finds himself behind bars